foreign
Town Chicago what's up Brittany hi Dr
John how are you good awesome what's up
um I am wondering how to grieve the
picture I had of a family for my son
whoo that's a hard one that's a big one
man what's so tell me more
okay
uh nine month old and and his dad and I
were back and forth we haven't been
together since the pregnancy and stuff
but we were back and forth and we've
been back and forth since he's been born
and recently he's kind of drawn the line
saying it's not going to work out we're
not going to be together
and my head knows it for the best but my
heart doesn't like that and because I've
always wanted a family dynamic because I
came from a divorced home so I didn't
really want that for my kids
um and I know that we're toxic together
we just we've tried and tried and just
doesn't work but I want to be able to
co-parent without wanting the Romantic
part with him uh okay so I was I was
gonna ask when you guys were back on and
back off
was it physical I mean was it mostly the
others hooking up and that you
were doing your best to woo him and win
him back and he was just
you know getting to hook up on the side
and you you had more invested than he
did or had y'all sat down and said let's
try to give us a run
um we've we did kind of both
in I think four years this year so we
were together for two straight and then
it was just kind of back and forth and
when he found out you were pregnant you
all broke up
um no we weren't together then
um we actually hooked up and that's how
okay so
um yeah
um
what does this guy bring you so let's
take your let's take your family picture
aside let's what does this guy bring you
he's obviously a great lover
like you keep going back you keep going
back even though you know it it it digs
your hole a little bit deeper right it
makes you feel worse every time but you
keep going back what is it about him
um honestly I feel like it's kind of all
like he wanted me and I wanted him and I
feel like kind of feel like that's all
I'm gonna ever get in life I guess
say more about that
like I don't know in a settling
um mindset I guess
um
well I got cheated on before him we were
I was married for about four years and
he cheated on me oh man okay
so you've had a series of all the way
back from when you're a kid of core
relationships falling apart in front of
you
and as a kid you feel really powerless
when Mom and Dad decide they're going
separate ways and married to somebody
that you love and you had said I'm all
in on you feel very powerless too
him saying hey I chose somebody else and
then yet again right yeah I'm sorry
how old are you uh 28 28
. so you're old enough to have a bunch
of scars relational scars and you're
young enough
that you still got your whole life ahead
of you yeah
called your little boy
uh he's nine months nine months
yeah tell me about him
oh he's great
um I don't know his babysitter say super
easy to take care of he's just a really
easy kid good sleeper he loves his food
so you you have created a picture in
your head this is how I wanted this to
go
the challenge with the picture you
created was
um and this isn't a knock this is just
me sitting by you and we're just owning
reality together okay
um you didn't have the skills and you
didn't have the partner to make that
picture a reality
so it became more of a wish than a
something I'm headed towards does that
make sense yeah and so
right now you're it's it's just entering
into a season of grief and it's a both
and I'm grieving I wanted this thing
and it's not here
and so
um I'm going to continue to say it out
loud you asked how I grieved this season
you say it out loud like what you just
said like you have a group of core
people that you could speak in and say
I'm sad today
and they say man we're sitting here with
you and
we're sad with you and at the same time
you begin learning new skills learning
to make meaning of this and head into
another Direction because if you don't
heal you're going to find yourself with
another guy that says yeah I want you
or at least want what you can do for me
and that will be enough for yet another
season
right yeah and you'll continue in that
cycle over and over and over again
why'd your parents get divorced
you have relationship with both your
parents
um I didn't talk to my dad from my
eighth grade year until I graduated high
school how come
um alcohol okay
so you had divorce on top of an addict
yeah
have you ever sat down and talked to
somebody
um I've seen I've seen a therapist
basically since I
um broke up with my with his death my
son's dad okay how's that been going not
well
um it's it's good
it's not really
why isn't it good
um
I mean I think I'm I think I'm learning
a lot and growing and stuff I just it's
the relationship parts that get me okay
so what I would tell you is
um if you're I can't tell you what to do
I'm just telling you if you were my
sister or you were my best buddy here's
what I would tell you okay
it will probably be a long while before
you don't like remember how great it was
sleeping with this guy
or in the moments that were really good
how deeply connected and loved he made
you feel
it's gonna be a long time until you
don't quote unquote feel that
and maybe you get married again have a
great husband and you show up to high
school graduation with your little boy
and his dad is there with his new wife
and you see him hug your son who's now
18 after he walks across the stage and
your heart skips a beat a little bit
all right so there's that feeling and
I'll tell anybody all day like the
feelings are fine that's okay that's
life
it's what are you going to do with that
feeling and so you can have the feeling
I still want to be with him or when I'm
going to drop off my son if he says hey
you want to come in you know what that
means
and you feel like yes but I'm not gonna
do that because now I'm healing and I'm
moving on with my life
and there's that gap between what I feel
like I want to do and what I know is the
right next move for me
and what you I wish I had a a more
clinical word than this but you got to
practice you just got to decide I'm
going to move into this area I'm gonna
practice
and it's going to feel lonely and it's
going to feel like you just you going to
work and then coming home and talking to
a blah blah blah and changing lots of
diapers and then repeat
um
and that's going to be why you have to
get other people in your life a couple
of friends that you can meet with and
that will be connected to you that's why
you have to have a counselor you've got
a history
of a little girl wondering why everybody
keeps leaving her
is that fair yeah very sure
foreign and at some point we have to say
they people did leave
and we're going to learn the new skills
moving forward so that we're not trying
to continually date and marry our
unfinished business but we're going to
create that picture that we've got in
our heart and mind
[Music]
that makes sense yeah
it's okay to be really really sad I'm
sorry
what's your next move
I don't know
are you sad about him are you sad about
that you found Yourself by yourself
or the exact thing that you didn't want
to have happen has happened
um I think I'm sad that just like
currently I'm lonely I guess but I want
what's best for my son
well what's best for
your son is that Mom is whole and what's
best for your son is that mom's got some
friends she can laugh with and play with
and bring over and maybe they can bring
up their little knucklehead kids and
then all of our kids can make big
knuckle-headed kid piles in the floor
right yeah
um
I say this with all love and due respect
loneliness at some point becomes a
choice it becomes a decision to that
that's I'm gonna sit in this I'm going
to baste in this or
I'm gonna Brave the Wilderness I'm going
back out and I might get
somebody might cheat on me again someone
might break up with me again and I'm not
suggesting you run out and start dating
again that may not be the right move
right now but I am suggesting
I'm gonna call some friends from work
and they're just gonna invite them over
we're gonna hang out I'm going to and
they can't stay very late because I got
a little boy and we gotta get him in the
bath we gotta get him to bed or maybe
they can stay late because we're gonna
get him to bed and then after that or
maybe I'm gonna pass him around and he's
going to get all kinds of love from two
or three other unstressed Out friends
um
foreign
that means you're gonna have to reach
again
and the last thing your body wants you
to do is to go be vulnerable again go
say hey will you be my friend again
because you got burned and you got
burned you got burned you got burned
what I'll tell you is
the only way to peace was having people
in your life
and my sister you gotta get the healing
that you need
at some point you gotta let that little
girl off the hook because she's still
playing defense for it you gotta let her
go play
God let that little girl go play
your mom and dad broke it up
dad got stuck in a bottle
first husband cheated on you
second hot second boyfriend baby daddy
said I'm out
it's a lonely dark place
the light here is you
and doing the next right thing